As a woman in my field,...
...it wasn't always so easy to pursue my dream of becoming a scientist,...
...but I followed my own path.
Growing up in Japan,...
...I was taught to have a strong sense of compassion and empathy for others,...
...and this value is central to my work as an epidemiologist.
In the past few years, I have been working at fighting COVID-19.
I'm proud of my work to help prevent the spread of diseases on a global scale.
I'm really glad to see that the Japanese government...
...is committed to supporting women in science...
...and funding more research at the university level,...
...and I look forward to seeing even more women...
...following their interest in science.